ومن البصره تنضم لان مراسله صباح العربيه
زينب المشاط زينب يسعد صباحك اليوم هو
اليوم الثالث والاخير لكي في تغطيه البصره
خليجي 25 صحيح نحن في العون ولكن كذلك في
البصره مع زينه نشكرك على هذه التغطيه
زينب نختمها اليوم معاكي بشان اشيل البصره
تفضلي
صباح الخير سهام طبعا شكرا لكم
البصره ومتابعتكم في خليجي 25 من البصره
والعراق يعني اتواجد انا اليوم في المنطقه
القديمه في البصره طبعا المنطقه القديمه
في البصره تعود الى همم
يعني الفتره اللي هي 14 هجري حيث كانت
الفتوحات الاسلاميه بالفتحات الاسلاميه
كانوا جنود همم يجب ان يسكنون على مقربه
من عوائلهم همم واحنا يخرجون الى رحله
الفتوحات او همم دهون الى الفتوحات همم
يعني حروب الفتوحات يجب ان يعود بواقه
السريع الى عوائلهم فبدل ان يسكن فيه شبه
الجزيره العربيه كنا منطقه بعيده عنهم همم
سكن في المنطقه القديمه في البصره
المنطقه القديمه في البصره تحتوي على
الشناشيل وعلى متاحف قديمه ايضا تخص
التراث العراقي وهذه الشناشيل طبعا تعود
الى العهد العثماني
وكلمه شراشيل هي اصلا كلمه عثمانيه تعني
اطلاله الملك مثل الملاحظ هذه الشناشير
خلفيه طبعا همم يعني احد هذه الشناشي
الخلفي هي عباره عن نوافذ نوافذ زجاجيه
ملونه وايضا همم يعني اطلالات شرف خشبيه
وابواب خشبيه مزخرفه بطريقه دقيقه جدا حتى
المباني يستخدمون فيها يعني مواد بناء
خاصه جدا هذه
الشناشيل يعني اليوم تعاني من همم يعني
امال تقريبا او نسيان نوع من النسيان
والامان همم عادت اليونسكو همم يعني اطلقت
اليونسكو مبادره لاعاده تاهيل وتطوير هذه
المدينه القديمه همم فاهتمت همم منطقه
نظران توجد فيها تقريبا 12 اا مبنى على
طراز الشناشيل ثلاثه منها تطلع على النهار
وتسعه منها همم تقع في منطقه في محله
الباشا في البصره
هذه المباني الثلاثه اللي تطل على نهر
طبعا تعود الى كيانات والشخصيات معروفه
جدا في البصره مثل البيت خزعه وبيت
المنديل وهؤلاء طبعا بيوت وكانت معروفه
جدا في البصره هذه المباني تحولت الى قصر
الثقافه والفنون في البصره وتحولت الى
جمعيه الفنانين التشكيليه واتحاد الادباء
في البصره بعد عنايه اليونسكو بيها وتستمر
طبعا اليونسكو بالعنايه واعاده التاهيل طب
انا كم مشاهد عربي عم تتابعك هلا في كثير
بلدان عربيه لديها منتشره يعني الشروفات
الخشبيه او كما تسمى الشناشير في البصره
هل الكاميرا او المصور ان يوجه الكاميرا
لهذه الاناشيد ما الذي يميزها عن باقي
الشروفات الخشبيه
نعم شناشيل اطلب من الكاميرا بالضبط ان
يصور
الشناشر الخلفيه اللي في العراق بالبدايه
طبعا يقال انه بنيت على ايدي يهود العراق
هذا الطراز المعماري بني على ايدي يهود
العراق وهو يتميز بالزخرفه الدقيقه
الاشكال مالتها الهندسيه الدقيقه والزخرفه
الدقيقه اضافه الى انه هي همم الزجاج
الخاص بها يكون زجاج ملون يعني والطابق
اللي يستخدم للبناء يكون طابق من نوع خاص
وهمم باحجام خاصه همم حاليا يعني احيانا
يعني مراحل اعاده تاهيل هذه الشراشيل همم
تتغير مواد البناء هذه يتسبب طبعا باضاعه
هويه المبنى يعني او البنايه لكن في
محاولات يعني اعاده تاهيلها من قبل
اليونسكو يعني هناك نوع من المحافظه كلها
الهندسيه
شكرا جزيلا مراسله صباح العربيه زينب
المشاط من البشره لليوم الثالث على
التوالي والاخير شكرا لك
[موسيقى]